almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it so I'm
getting more and more calls from viewers
and listeners horrified that Donald
Trump is going to cheat his way to
re-election later this year and your
fears are real and that Donald Trump
will try to cheat the question is
whether he will succeed and what we mean
by cheating and Heather Digby Parton has
a really great article in salon about
this and I'll mention a few of her
points in a few of mine she points out
that as real as Joe Biden's leads in the
polls right now may well be Donald Trump
will try to cheat and it was going to
take everything we have to keep him from
re-election now what do I mean by
cheating and I want to be really careful
here by cheating I mean that failures
and vulnerabilities in the system will
lead to Donald Trump maybe being
reelected even when a Biden win would be
the will of the people so I'll give you
an example of what I mean by that
Trump's opposition to vote-by-mail this
has been a big thing over the last three
or four weeks whether we call it literal
cheating legal cheating or simply
suppressing the will of the people
Trump trying to win by making it so
fewer people vote is cheating in the
sense that it cheats democracy it's
circumvent the will of the people
yesterday I told you about you know all
the garbage math that we're going to be
hit by in the coming months where people
who don't even understand growth rates
and percentages are going to quickly be
told that we're seeing the fastest
growing economy in history in the
upcoming third quarter when what we're
seeing is the start of a recovery from
the largest declines of the last hundred
years so that's not literally cheating
but it is bamboozling vulnerable people
with mathematical lies another example
Trump has an Attorney General in place
William bar
William bar has made it clear that he
has absolutely no moral and ethical
scruples whatsoever he will stop at
nothing to help Donald Trump now you
might think well hold on a second David
William bar did recently say he's not
going to prosecute Obama in the fake
Obama gate scandal he must realize that
that's not okay he's doing the ethical
thing no all that means is that William
Bar recognizes that in the large scheme
of things a good prosecuting Barack
Obama for the bogus Obama gate Fiasco
first of all there's no crime Obama
committed so what could you really
prosecute him for he recognizes that
it's not the right tool to use to try to
propel Donald Trump to re-election
Election Day is going to be absolute
mayhem in red states you're gonna see
people show up to vote and told that
they're not registered due to voter
purges you're going to see the polling
places that are open we don't know how
many it's going to be it'll depend on
the virus you're going to see some
polling places completely overloaded in
key swing states like Wisconsin and
Pennsylvania and Florida you're going to
see some so-called Patriots showing up
to do security at polling places which
of course will be hugely intimidating to
certain voters you're going to see even
in states that go for vote-by-mail a
concerted effort to disqualify ballots
for bogus reasons you're going to see
coronavirus probably keep more Democrats
at home than Republicans because
Democrats are more likely to understand
and accept the medical science of
coronavirus when Republicans are more
likely to ignore it so understand that
we have an election coming up and it's
not unique in this sense but it's
exacerbated acutely in this particular
election we have an election coming up
where one candidate wants to reduce the
number of people that vote and the other
candidate wants as many people as
possible to vote lastly understand that
this is only partially because of
coronavirus even before the corona virus
pandemic in 2017 there was a poll done
asking if Trump suggested postponing the
election would you support it
more than half of Republicans said they
would more than half of Republicans
before the virus said we would support
postponing the election just on Trump's
say-so
it's not going to happen this year
remember that it's up to the states
there's not a federal election in
November what we have is an election of
a federal government position President
of the United States done by 50
individual state elections each state
election is administered independently
but the anti-democratic tendencies of
the Republican Party have been clear for
a long time it's scaled up because
Donald Trump knows it's not things he
knows and he's right that if he can keep
disproportionately Democrats from voting
including by blocking vote-by-mail he is
in a much better position to potentially
defeat Joe Biden in November so what do
we have to do well number one we've got
to completely overwhelm the voting
booths in November and I hate that it's
the only surefire method but if we
completely overwhelm the voting booths
and vote-by-mail absentee ballots
everything that ensures that we win
Trump can only cheat so much and if we
don't allow him to prevent people from
voting one way or another that is very
very important now secondly we've got to
keep pushing on vote-by-mail
particularly in certain states and I'm
going to address that a little bit more
in the next segment but understand if we
overwhelm the voting booths he can't win
we just need to do it